hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the great
work okay I was overthinking it
I didn't even check my inventory to
remember that I had a hammer in chipper
so I used that on that perfectly fine
right away so let's go in here see what
else we got I was going all over the
place looking for a hidden switch
answer was right in front of me the
whole time let's light this candle save
some oil it pains me to seal the clock
so soon after its completion what clock
no choice escaped from college forced to
use all of my alcaman sirs off searing
their flesh leaving none left to carry
out my plan dead monsters in my clothes
hacked it to pieces that's how he faked
his death they break through my barriers
i thankfully have other means of defense
my guardians are not all-powerful but
they should slow the monster progress
Samuel
hey it's Samuel hmm I don't have a good
feeling about this Samuel guy he doesn't
quite seem like he's on the up-and-up
give me that give it gosh I got I almost
angered me that would have been hard
than this if I wasn't the world's
greatest detective Wow
d'argo okay let's go so I'm gonna come
busting through there I bet I bet boy I
bought do bit
AHA bet okay key to the rare books
section the Necronomicon the anti
goodness book of dastardly deeds The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy it's
awfully well lit who leaves candles LED
in the in the rare book section who's in
that a little dangerous Oh while I was
wandering there's apparently the sounds
of someone else going through the
library scholars are divided on origin
to practitioners Zorro's Ryan few
material survive no public ceremony
mithril I am sunken below the you little
windowless remains hidden rituals
consecrated sacrilege the exact shape
okay sorry I'm not reading everything
but don't quite have time this is an
exceptionally long story you don't need
to hear me blathering on
okay so I'm willing to bet there's
something hidden in this room so I got a
check every single shelf systematically
so let's start with this side
shooters in here no however no thanks
going over no that's like a big bug no
say nothing in this shelf behind us for
that yeah oh oh so shelf is your rah rah
come on ah come on rock ah Jesus Christ
come on holy balls holy balls Oh God
aren't you doing anything
holy crap this is dog loss seemed to be
working
ah come on fall on me I'll catch you get
all the books off yet make it a little
less heavy oh man physics at its finest
is like trying to swing that statue
earlier would not move
you'd think far as leverage goes there
we go got to work the lever work the
leverage Omaha what this let me get one
of these heavy books ah not some heavy
reading okay whoa
s looks like some Illuminati up in this
[ __ ] with the help of the great
engineers of the circle the second first
style advances at midnight on December
31st second dial advances on the
beginning of the new century clock will
keep time accurately for the next 10,000
years
fancy I have built it not to record what
regular people perceive its time but
what the universe perceives as deep time
this clock will continue to tick after I
have died after the family his
disappearance disappeared from existence
buried beneath the library the gears
have been crafted from the finest metals
with resist corrosion over the centuries
the steam system is pressurized by the
weight of the dry
with new drivers a raise the clock is
Wow
interesting nice clock buddy let's see
when one of these numbers say while I'm
trapped behind this couch
thank you 18:28 okay it seems nice
oh this is that door that was boarded up
okey-dokey so let's go through here see
what we've got waiting for us on the
other side no no no no no no no no [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
God light light thank you what do we got
waiting for us there's nothing in here
what what's in here sack of potatoes
rotten potatoes Oh what what I've Oh
stutters oh oh oh whoa next Victor has
hartleb concentrated on the stone he
suddenly became aware of the universe
information poured into his mind and
back out again maurienne caught him as
he stumbled under the weight of
everything hartleb hesitated momentarily
before allowing himself to become the
locus of all knowledge that samuel
hartleb i do not trust that guy oh no it
looks like no my amnesia is crashing ah
bollocks okay maíam knees is crashing
poop-poop
this happens every once in a while okay
I'll be back as soon as I can
and we're back okay thank you everybody
for your patience we are back going into
the depths of despair
down here all now water high water why
water
Oh what what did I do
was that what was that was that was that
no I don't need that oh come on that's
not even fair oh this is not even fair
hey the water mother am i dying
go over
there okay okay such ball oh okay I need
to take this with me so that I have
something to stand on but I can't run
with this come on okay I'm okay I'm okay
okay okay oh you [ __ ] pipes okay okay
what the hell what is a moveable oh
where am I going what am i doing where
are ya where are ya not gonna give me
oh man oh I see I see I see you can I
reach you no I cannot I need to get one
of these boxes over here do it gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme go ha ha ha
screw you you're an [ __ ] Oh gimme oh
come on I can't raise that Oh bollocks
I need another box where's another box I
don't see another box oh wait I'm up
here already oh I can get up here okay
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine I don't need
another box okay all right
ow ow why did I do that
bend your knees man okay the fall badly
injured me I have to heal okay I think I
have one loud down am left I'm still in
bad shape though all right there we go
oh no they're gonna give me any extra
down
shut up Daniel
hello hi huh baby startled me sorry ha
hey honey
oh you so fine why is it all scorched in
black why do I have a ringing in my ears
why am I in this place whatever oh come
on
I just put oil in thank you anyway
okay lever what did i do what did I do
what that do what that go never what
that dope okay so these levers go to
this device here do something else I'm
looking at here something else I need to
know something else something I'm not
right something okay so maybe it's a
quicker timer than I think how about
down no down not work up and then this
one down
okay those do not last long
oh but what why what okay I don't get it
but that worked what happened what had
happened was not an accident
there was a will governing this stone
and that was why it had reacted so
violently moraines touch but not his
hartleb wondered if they had for our
short a moment caught God's Akash I know
that's gotta be custom that's cool it
reminds me of something I've seen of
machine for pigs the vacant mansion in
Dartmouth was perfect for their purposes
its sat on a plot of land just outside
the main city peaceful and secluded blah
blah blah large cellar renovated into a
zip or oh god this is in a laboratory
this is the oven shouldn't be run
without everything in place I don't even
know what I'm putting in place what am i
putting in place here though the shard
is merely a broken object now with
intense concentration and repeated
practice I have been able to draw out a
great deal of its power widely varied
incredible legendary solvent the true
Alka has incredible life-extending
properties I wonder what effect it would
have on human my biggest percent is that
Johann is not here to see this day I am
finally succeeding where where have I
heard Johann before I think I've heard
Johann in the main storyline okay what
did I get there's no more car mont left
to use car MOT Carmen how do I even know
what Carmen is I know I read a few notes
here and there but that does not make me
an alcohol expert on anything oh good
man they are letting me have oil all
over the place I love it I'll hold off
on refilling therefore just a little bit
longer okay what's going on here why am
i being blocked from going up and it
stop y'all okay let me try this don't
need that why am I wasting my oil just
cuz I have oil readily available doesn't
mean I need to waste it okay what is
this it's gonna tell me no lantern is
now fully refueled with my extremely
fast burning oil hello oh how nice
that gives an atmospheric glow if I ever
saw one
most of amnesia is red lit because of
all the torches it's nice to have some
bloosh blue shaving in here some
different color variables and okay one
Rose picked up a rose roses and feared
was a strange substance
okay nothing else here that I can use
the Rose is all I need however I am all
out it was that chair always there I
don't know I am all out of time so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
there's any tips and trips that I need
to know for the next part please let me
know but so far I'm getting through this
pretty quickly so thank you again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]